a Donald Trump has now gone over the
line into full-blown conspiracy theories
you might say hold on a second David
hasn't he always been a conspiracy
theorist I mean Obama born in another
country the birther stuff
Hillary cheated on the popular vote with
3 to 5 million illegal voters the molar
investigation is a democratic setup
whatever that's true but now Trump is
actually jumping onto a bigger and more
established conspiracy theory that of
the deep state what is the deep state so
generally deep state means it's the idea
of a group of powerful people typically
everybody ranging from government
sometimes very wealthy plutocrats
military who are working together to
secretly manipulate government and world
policy maybe for their benefit this is
at the level of like the Illuminati or
the Bilderberg Group conspiracies
whatever Donald Trump is fully in on
this now Trump claimed in a tweet of
course where else is he going to do it
that the United States Justice
Department is part of the deep state
tweeting crooked Hillary Clinton's top
aide humi Abaddon has been accused of
disregarding basic security protocols
she put classified passwords why
classified passwords is capitalized we
will never know into the hands of
foreign agents remember sailors pictures
on submarine jail deep State Justice
Department must finally act also on
Comey and others it's important not to
understate or misunderstand what it is
that Donald Trump is suggesting here the
President of the United States is saying
that the American Justice Department as
a result of being controlled and
manipulated by this shadowy group of
co-conspirators is going after him but
not human Abbadon and crooked Hillary
and that the former FBI director James
Comey is involved in this if your crazy
uncle at Thanksgiving who works in
accounting comes up with this you don't
really worry too much if Cletus who
changes your oil tells you this you say
ok they're misinformed but it really
doesn't have a major impact this is the
president of the United States
who believes that there is a conspiracy
by which the Justice Department has been
co-opted by a secret group of powerful
people working together for I guess
their gain rather than fulfilling their
role as the top law-enforcement agency
of the United States our own president
appears to believe that there is a
shadow government and that it is
conspiring against him personally
yeah it really doesn't make sense that
he could still be a conspiracy theorist
too because you know I can understand
maybe back during the election when he
was calling the system rigged and that
everything was against him you can kind
of rationalize how he would come to that
position now later he's in charge and he
can pick the people who are in the
Justice Department in the FBI which he
calls corrupt it doesn't hold up anymore
well that's why it's even crazier
because the most interesting about the
interesting thing to me about this is
that those who believe in the deep state
usually believe that the president is an
irrelevant puppet with no real power or
say so right the deep state really has
the power the president has no power I
know I'm going further here than Trump
ever could in his thinking which is so
simplistic but by Trump's tacit
admission that the deep state exists and
is in control of the Justice Department
Trump is effectively saying he is an
irrelevant puppet in other words if the
deep state exists Trump has no power and
Trump is saying that the deep state
exists he's parroting conspiracy
theories often right-wing ones but he's
kind of framing them as nationalistic in
some way to go with this faux populist
rhetoric that he's been using now for
over a couple years and the problem is
that the deep state right it involves
the military and the Pentagon and these
areas of government that it's normally
the American right that really likes
these are not lefty agencies that Trump
is picking a fight with and discrediting
it's the ones that the right typically
defends how is that going to work out
for him because he's basically putting
himself at direct odds with the military
Pentagon and FBI which are not
organizations that the right usually
picks fights with he's taken a few
different positions simultaneously yes
we've seen it before and he can justify
anything with it send me your thoughts
I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman the show is on twitter at
david pakman show we've got a great
program for you today and a couple very
interesting announcements coming up
after the break
today's program is made possible in part
by
Gamefly which is sort of like netflix
for video games they've got over 8,000
new and classic games for xbox one Xbox
360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can also stream games
you don't even need a gaming console or
a computer because you can stream games
through your Amazon fire stick or Roku
box and then use your mobile phone as
the controller you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price never with due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a 30-day free
trial at Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included no
contracts and you can also stream the
games I think I mentioned that you can
also rent games through the mobile app
get a free 30 day trial for david pakman
show viewers and listeners and support
our show at Gamefly offer.com forward
slash TDP s